it was at the start of today's Court
proceedings that Damien Bendel entered
guilty pleas guilty to the murder of his
partner Terry Harris who was in the
early stages of pregnancy with their
child guilty to the murder of 11 year
old Lacey Bennett and 13 year old John
Bennett who were Terry's children from a
previous relationship and also guilty to
the murder of 11 year old Connie gent
who was Lacey's friend who was staying
at the Home in killer Marsh in
Derbyshire for a sleepover on the night
that these terrible events unfolded he
also pleaded guilty to the rape of 11
year old Lacey Bennett a rate that this
court has been hearing was carried out
as Lacey Lay Dying in her home the
details are just horrendous he took a
claw hammer and he hit his victims
around the head he chased them around
the house they were all found in
different rooms of the house with
horrifying head injuries
we saw video of the two girls
um Lacey and Connie earlier in the day
the children had spent that day making a
sweet store selling sweets to the
neighbors to raise money for cancer
research and the police understand that
it was as the children were getting
ready for bed that Damian bendahl
embarked on this Terror terrifying
murderous Rampage around the house now
we know that he was a drug addict we
know that he'd been trying to get hold
of drugs it's believed that he was under
the influence of drugs but it's
described as an inexplic inexplicable
and motivless attack now the following
morning he then took the Xbox of the
young boy who he'd murdered took it to a
drug dealer's house to exchange the Xbox
for drugs
he spoke to his mother on the phone and
she then called police to report that
she thought that her son had
self-inflicted stab wounds and it was as
the police arrived at the house Damien
Bendel made a bizarre call to 999 to say
that the police had arrived but that
he'd murdered four people now we saw a
video that from the police body worn
cameras of those officers arriving they
clearly didn't believe Damien bendahl's
claims at first that he'd murdered four
people but then we heard audio from
those body-worn cameras as an officer
went round the house clearly
increasingly upset by what he was seeing
and you could just hear him say the
words they're gone they're gone as I
said members of the families were in
court we heard
some Victim Impact statements Jason
Bennett the father of Lacey and John
Paul described his life as like living
in a continual nightmare he said I won't
see them grow up I won't be given the
opportunity to be a grandpa I'm lost
without them and Charles gent the father
of Connie gent said my heart is
completely broken this will haunt me for
the rest of my life now Damian vandal's
Barrister has accepted that a whole life
tariff would be acceptable in this case
and pandal is going to be sentenced this
afternoon